imaginons peau en locaux comme aj
manquer les enfants de machines de man
depuis 1946 onze hommes et une femme ont
présidé sous différentes formes cette
assemblée de proximité la préfecture
nassimah dindar a occupé cette fonction
pendant 13 ans de 2004 à 2010 est une
responsabilité devant l'histoire
une exigence morale qui engage
l'individu et tout son environnement
dans un travail acharné pour un
développement durable de notre île une
dynamique politique pour cette
institution qui se résume en quatre axes
qui sortent parfois des seuils
d'obligation légale du département la
solidarité sociale l'économie
l'aménagement du territoire et enfin
l'épanouissement humain
[Musique]
le département accompagne le réunionnais
du premier cri au dernier soupir
et dans ces étapes de vie la solidarité
sociale permet d'améliorer les
conditions de vie de notre population en
mutation crime que je n'ai la protection
maternelle infantile accompagne sur
toute l'île tout ce qui touche à
l'enfance l'enfant dans toute sa
dimension oblige l'impulsion d'outils
innovants pour n'en citer qu'un les
maisons d'accueil maternelle viennent
ensuite les années collège et au delà
des conditions d'enseignement
l'éducation du citoyen de demain a
conduit une politique volontariste à
travers les collèges en musique qui
fêtent leurs 10 ans cette année
[Musique]
ou encore le cdj et bien d'autres
opérations telles que nos gaspille où
les collèges fleuri à l'envers
le décrochage scolaire étant une réalité
la mandature de nassimah dindar a vu
naître l'académie des dalons un coup de
pouce qui prouve que chaque jour c'est
possible d or et non au contraire
beaucoup de fierté parce que certaines
injustices ont conduit la collectivité a
voté des dispositifs tels que
l'accompagnement des malades en
métropole et pour nos gramounes clé de
voûte de notre population
plusieurs outils permettent aujourd'hui
un mieux vivre le shaq santé ou encore
la réhabilitation de l'habitat insalubre
ont corrigé ces situations c'est pas non
rien
ces solidarités sociales qui sont ici au
service de la solidarité économie après
conférence en moi même ma fille je me
suis ressourcé et dis donc je suis pas
tout seul il y avait ce répit aux
couleurs
le département a toujours été un acteur
essentiel à la réunion une fois cela dit
comment mener une action cohérente pour
un développement économique
[Musique]
l'insertion cette notion a toujours été
au centre des dispositifs l'innovation
des derniers mandats s'appelle plein
d'ambition jeunesse tous les contrats
jeunes qui se sont succédé ou encore l'
académie des dalons est l'outil qui a
fait ses preuves reste la création de la
filière bois de goyavier une performance
présent modèle qui illustre
l'intelligence institutionnelle qu'il a
fallu développer au fil des années
la mobilité reste une solution avec
comme outil le cnps armes et pour les
entrepreneurs depuis 20 ans déjà le
challenge des créateurs a permis de
faire savoir que c'est possible
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le monde rural fait partie de cette
économie 200 millions d'euros par an le
chiffre parle de lui-même le monde
agricole a toujours été une priorité at
direct ou sectorielles ce travail permet
à la collectivité de contribuer au
quotidien au développement des filières
une vision de territoire participative
permet de voir plus loin des conventions
avec des communes ont été passées et
permettront demain de partager le savoir
faire des agents du département
[Musique]
parlons justement de l'espace et comment
on la ménage une préoccupation de tout
les mandatures
car anticipée et les plus grands défis
le développement des os voilà le défi de
ces dernières années les 720 km de
routes départementales dont 420 km sont
des routes de montagne avec 400 ouvrages
d'art voilà un des défis relevés chaque
jour par les agents de la collectivité
[Applaudissements]
une impulsion positive qui se traduit
par une dynamique économique c'est
l'histoire de l'irrigation du littoral
ouest
un grand projet qui fait partie
aujourd'hui des paysages tout comme le
pilotage de la politique de l'eau les
forêts départementaux domaniale
représente 40% du territoire une
richesse pas uniquement touristique et
botanique
voilà la vision de la mandature
protection n'est pas incompatible avec
valorisation et création de richesse de
ses 58 ans c'est pour cela que dès les
premières heures nassimah dindar a
soutenu la candidature des pitons
cirques et remparts au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco
fiers de notre île de son territoire et
de sa population
cela a toujours été la ligne conductrice
gros capital de nouna le premier capital
donner à ces deux régions
parce que là des profs dans son argent
sa terre ils portent sont végétales il
vole sa roche volcanique c'est peut-être
ce beau temps d'observation
il pose ce qui sait faire avec le nez
c'est à dire tout ça sur papier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les réunionnais sont formidables plus
qu'un concept une conviction donner
envie d'avoir envie pourrait être ainsi
la formule la valorisation d'acteurs
connus et parfois mal connus de notre
société s'est fait chaque année par le
prix départemental du mérite
un instant de reconnaissance qui a fait
beaucoup de bien à ses maillons forts
notre culture plurielle un dia océanique
et européennes a toujours été considérée
comme une richesse
le prix célimène avec la valorisation
des femmes artistes ou encore la
reconnaissance du rôle bâtisseurs du
lazaret dans notre identité
voilà deux bons exemples phares
passagers au nom du gouverneur de notre
charmante colonies bienvenus le sport
autres médias d'expression de notre
population n'est pas oublié avec d'une
part un accompagnement sans faille de la
masse à travers les associations et
d'autre part la pratique du haut niveau
au bonheur des enfants la dernière
opération de nassimah dindar comme
présidente de la collectivité est une
belle illustration donner du bonheur une
valeur immatérielle un moteur pour
l'homme réunionnais en fin d'année on a
envie d'ouvrir son compteur on a envie
de partager de belles choses de faire
rayonner des étoiles dans la tête de
tout le monde pas seulement des
tout-petits et je crois qu'en le réussir
trouvée dans un lot offert par l'appel
[Musique]
impossible de résumer 13 ans d'action
politique mais retenons que l'humain
dans toute sa dimension est restée la
préoccupation centrale
[Musique]
nous tous ensemble
oui
[Musique]
faux
tout a été fait
super beau mais dans son nom fait un
faux pas tous là
deux autres filles come on for 115 me
taire non faut pas tous les temps nous
les thèmes on ne nous dit pas tout faire
pour mettre ensemble pour mettre
ensemble pour mettre ensemble
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]